en esta estación de bomberos cerca de
Varsovia se están preparando para lo
peor los bomberos acaban de recibir del
gobierno reservas de pastillas de yoduro
de potasio un medicamento contra la
radiación lo que les convierte en el
primer punto de distribución para la
población de la ciudad las pastillas nos
han llegado por sorpresa pero estamos
Por así decirlo preparados los
residentes Están preocupados preguntan
Cómo se supone que funcionan o cuando se
van a necesitar las autoridades del país
han establecido una red de puntos de
distribución en escuelas ayuntamientos y
parques de bomberos de todo el país en
medio de los crecientes temores en torno
a la central eléctrica de zaporilla en
la vecina Ucrania actualmente ocupada
por las fuerzas rusas y las autoridades
polacas quieren estar preparadas
se trata de una preparación en caso de
accidente en una central nuclear las
pastillas que contienen yo estable están
destinadas a bloquear la glándula
tiroides ante una posible exposición a
la reactividad Por el momento no hay una
amenaza real de contaminación radiactiva
pero queremos estar preparados incluso
para lo imposible ni mordidas variante
el mes pasado la Unión Europea envió
Ucrania reservas de más de 5 millones de
pastillas anti radiación como medida de
seguridad preventiva y en Finlandia las
farmacias están desabastecidas ya que su
gobierno limitó las pastillas a los
menores de 40 años